hey guys Pete here this will be my
better call Saul season 5 episode 10
trailer breakdown in preview it's
already time for the season finale I
can't believe how fast this season has
gone by and just how good it's been
thankfully it won't be the last we
already know there's 13 more episodes
coming after this one in a longer season
6 the series will end there but before
we can think about that we have episode
10 which is titled something
unforgivable to close out season 5 this
is your quick spoiler warning this video
will contain spoilers about everything
that's happened in better call Saul
leading up to the finale of season 5
we're also going to talk about things
that happen in Breaking Bad so if you're
not caught up or you don't like
speculation about what's to come then
this video won't be for you consider
yourself warned after episode 9 we've
arrived at the end of the season and we
found ourselves in new territory Jimmy
McGill 'he's two worlds have officially
intersected with each other when Lalo
Salamanca knocked on the door of his
apartment all hopes for him keeping his
wife Kim Wexler out of the game faded
away the legal world in the criminal
world are now all wrapped up in one
since this is a prequel show and we
already know the fates of many of the
characters it's pretty amazing how hard
it is to predict what will happen next
a lot of that uncertainty is related to
Lalo and what he plans to do after he
walked out of Jimmy & Kim's apartment he
told not sure they were going to Mexico
which this trailer confirms but his next
move is a complete mystery everything
hinges on that showdown with Kim and no
matter how many times I rewatched that
scene I can't see where he gives a hint
to what he's thinking she may have
convinced him that he can't trust anyone
and that he needs to get his house in
order or she may have impressed him with
her talk of shell companies in the
Cayman Islands or it could just be like
Tony Dalton described it in an interview
he saw that he was thinking about all
this too much and in reality now that
he's out of jail everything is fine
everything is not fine with Jimmy Jimmy
is battered from his experience and
certainly not operating at a hundred
percent before Kim stepped in there was
almost no Saul Goodman on display as
Lalo forced him to retell the story of
what happened in the desert I'm not
really sure if he's gonna recover from
that by the end of the season and that
might be okay
I mean he has Kim on his side and she's
proven herself to be fierce when it's
necessary the episode description for
something unforgivable doesn't provide
much help either
it reads Jimmy and Kim make a sideways
move that takes a serious turn
nacho gets closer to the cartel than
he'd like and listen I'm not complaining
I think it's awesome that I can be this
engaged with the TV show and not know
what's going to happen next the seasons
been great and I expect that to continue
let's break down the preview trailer
scene by scene and then I'll toss out
some ideas I have kicking around in my
head the trailer opens with Kim and
Jimmy still in the apartment just after
Lalo leaves Jimmy's on the phone
presumably talking to Mike and he asks
so what happens next this is promising
and that we might get to see Jimmy and
Kim talk about what just happened but
there's no sign of that anywhere in this
trailer
Jimmy's words indicate that maybe he
wants to try to do something to try to
protect Kim but I can't imagine that
Mike will let him do anything other than
sit back and pretend that nothing
happened this could put him in a weird
spot where he wants to make things right
in his mind but his hands will be tied
he'll basically be unable to act and
that might have a really negative effect
on him next we see Gus outside the
burndown los Pollos site he's walking by
a rollaway dumpster we see the burnt up
sign and things inside and here we see
the only one episode left this season
title flash up on the image Gus says
well to someone off screen and we don't
know what he says after that this is
probably Mike I'm not sure who else it
could be
and he's probably there to fill him in
on what happened at the apartment then
we see a shot of razor wire on top of
the wall giving the feeling of a heavily
fortified compound at the gate we see a
man with an automatic weapon and a knife
on his belt there's a black truck with a
Chihuahua license plate that pulls up
and we can't see who's inside it this
could be anybody that's related to the
cartel Donal adios cartel is referred to
as the cuidado Juarez cartel that's a
city that's in Chihuahua so I'm guessing
that all the characters we know Juan
bolsa Don Eladio all of them live in
that place back in their bed
Kim says well do you know something
you're not telling me to Jimmy we can
see sunlight coming in so it's daytime
and Kim is dressed to go out like she's
dressed professionally she's wearing
this blue shirt which I think she's
wearing throughout the rest of the
scenes that we see it's hard to tell
though because she's not wearing a
jacket here and then the other scene she
is since she doesn't have a job I
imagine she's going to the courthouse to
do pro bono work either way she's going
out and Jimmy doesn't look like he's
going anywhere next we see nacho in
Mexico and he's talking to someone on
his phone he just says yeah there's
nothing else there that cuts to a shot
of a phone that flashes a no service
message it could be nachos phone it
could be someone else's there's nothing
to connect it to anything we hear Lalo's
say don't think I don't see you alright
he's working on a car and nachos looking
on this looks like it's probably his
home and it would make sense that it
would be behind those guarded walls we
saw earlier after that mike tells Jimmy
you're asking for information you can't
have based on what they're wearing
this looks connected to the sneak peek
video for episode 10 and that would mean
this conversation is inside Mike's house
in that clip we saw that Jimmy found out
where Mike lived and he went over there
to ask questions
Jimmy's probably trying to put things
together and Mike is probably trying to
keep Gus's identity secret the sneak
peek video is pretty funny we see Jimmy
alternating between ringing the bell and
hitting the door sort of shouting and
then we see Mike pull up in the
background that cuts to a shot of Kim
talking to Howard in an empty courtroom
we don't hear any of their dialogue and
they both have serious looks on their
faces
this feels surprising to see these two
characters together it's pretty hard to
guess at what they might be talking
about Howard could be congratulating her
for getting married he could be telling
her about the bowling balls and the
prostitutes he could be offering her a
job there's a lot of possibilities but
none of them seem exactly right next we
see Jimmy at home in bed staring up at
the ceiling he still looks like he's
struggling to get over the events he's
been living through and it looks like
he's trying to figure out what his next
move is that's followed by a nighttime
shot of Kim and Jimmy sitting on the bed
she asks you're not going to do it again
and while she's talking we see three big
blocks of cash wrapped in plastic it's
not clear where the cash is or what's
going on with it
it's possible that the cartel wants
Jimmy to move it again based on what she
says or it could just be misdirection in
the trailer then we get a shot of nacho
coming through a door and it's too dark
to tell what's going on I'm guessing
that this is still at Lalo's compound or
somewhere south of the border and it's
probably connected to a scene we'll see
a little bit later that cuts to a shot
of Lalo lounging drinking a beverage
over these shots we hear Kim say oh my
god and voiceover we then see her
walking into a room filled with boxes
she's being led by someone who was just
out of the frame when I stopped it and
looked at it closely the person has a
dark complexion and is wearing a suit
his hair is cropped neatly and so this
could actually be Gus but I really don't
want to believe that's true I tried to
take a close look at the boxes but
couldn't make out anything that was
written on them it looks important but
it's also mysterious then we see this
shot of someone firing a gun in a
kitchen it's hard to make anything out
when the flash dies down it does look
like it's at nighttime and that's why I
thought this was connected to that
earlier shot of nacho coming into the
house but it doesn't look like it's
nacho that's holding the gun the best I
can do is that someone is gonna shoot up
something somewhere sometime during this
episode the next shot is of Jimmy
sitting on the edge of the bed thinking
Kim's under the covers and she rolls and
turns off the light it fades the black
and then we see a close-up shot of Kim's
eye looking through a peephole and a
door I think the people is the one
that's on their front door at their
apartment and she could just be looking
at it after Lalo leaves the apartment on
that first night it's hard to say so
that's where the trailer ends and like I
said it's exciting because we don't know
what's going to happen if you think
about it long enough something
unforgivable could apply to every one of
the characters and their situations
Jimmy could do something unforgivable
Kim could do something unforgivable Lalo
could make nacho do something
unforgivable and so on I really don't
know to revisit the description it says
nacho gets closer to the cartel than
he'd like considering Lalo has to stay
out of the u.s. I'm guessing that their
time in Mexico is gonna involve him
having to prove his loyalty but I can't
tell you how that's going to play out we
have to imagine that when he leaves when
nacho goes back he's essentially handing
him the keys to the kingdom
until Tuco gets out of jail which is
what he was telling hector about just a
little while ago he told Saul he didn't
trust him enough to give him the 7
million dollar so there's potential for
something to go down there I'm really
curious as to what the teaser will be in
the previous seasons the cold open for
the finale has always been a flashback
we saw Jimmy back in Cicero we saw Chuck
and Jimmy as kids we saw Chuck and Jimmy
when their mother died and we saw them
when Jimmy became a lawyer and they were
out celebrating I always like when they
do flashbacks like that so I'm really
looking forward to see how they'll do it
this season it could turn out to be one
of a completely different character like
we could get another Kim flashback or
maybe even Lalo flashback I'm also
curious to see whether Jimmy's gonna get
it together and what Kim plans to do now
that she has walked away from Schweikart
and Cokely Jimmy wasn't too happy about
the idea but when she said that she'll
come up with a plan I believe her I know
a lot of people think she might go full
crime I mean it's possible in light that
she's already tied up with the situation
but I think the big thing coming out of
the last episode about their
relationship is is that we know that she
is all in for Jimmy and that's equally
as important as her being in the game
the Howard thing is a complete mystery
as well like he could offer her a job
but why would she take it she just left
a partner position I don't know how the
Howard job would be any different it's
not to say it's not possible but it is
difficult to predict
we've also generally lost a character or
there was a death in the end of the
season and I'm not sure if that's gonna
happen this time or not the way things
are as it is right now it'd be hard to
see any of the major characters taken
off the board but no way impossible
based on Gus's phone call it seems that
Wan bolsa has figured out that the
problems that Gus is having are coming
from wallow this could spell the end for
him but it's kind of hard to imagine how
that would play out he's had such a big
influence on the story and they've
crafted this character in such a way
that he does such a good job being a
worthy adversary to Gus but then also to
Jimmy Saul Goodman because he excels in
some of the same areas of being able to
be charismatic and to manipulate things
just like Saul does so it would be
pretty surprising if he was
but it could definitely happen I don't
know and that's a good thing going into
this I'm really excited we got 14
episodes to this story ends and I feel
like this next one's gonna be a big one
so let me know in the comments what you
think what you're hoping to see do you
think someone's gonna die do you think
that there's gonna be some major changes
how will next season set up and where
are we going from here please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon